see oslo remote
all right and it is 6 40 so why don't we
go ahead and get started
good morning good afternoon and good
evening everybody i
am mickey gousei i'm a devops architect
on the microsoft dev customer advisory
team
and i'm here in the next hour to talk to
you about
building a devops culture and about our
journey and specifically the azure
devops
engineering team's journey to adopting
both an agile mindset
and building out a devops culture that
has kind of flowed throughout all of
microsoft
as i mentioned i'm a member of the
devops customer advisory team and my
part of my job is to go out and help
people get more devopsy
whatever that might mean but i have to
ask you something very
important first do you know what tupelo
mississippi is world famous for
so i am from tupelo mississippi it is a
small
30 000 person town in northeast
mississippi and it gets about
10 000 people a year that come to my
town to visit probably half of which
come from europe actually
so normally i'd pull the audience but
what i'll do instead is just tell you
we are famous because we are the
birthplace of elvis presley
that's right elvis presley was born in a
two-room not a two-bedroom but a
two-room house
in tupelo mississippi so people come to
tupelo they tour his house they tour the
church
they go to the hardware store downtown
where he bought his first guitar at age
nine which is still a hardware store
still owned by the same people that sold
him that guitar and then they go up to
memphis tennessee to see grace lynch
which is where he lived when he got
famous
so that's my small town's claim to fame
but let's face it you're not here to
listen to me talk about duplo
mississippi
you're here to listen to me talk about
devops and
our devops journey here at microsoft
and to do that we first have to start
off by defining what we mean by devops
and if you've been to any microsoft
presentation on devops in the past
couple of years
then you've seen this definition so
donovan brown came up with our
definition which is
devops is the union of people process
and products to enable the continuous
delivery of
value to our end users and there is a
lot of goodness in that statement
people processing products those are the
three things
out of those three things products
least important which may sound strange
coming from
somebody whose company sells a product
that's called azure devops
but products is the least important
there are so many products out there
that you can use
to help you drive your devops journey
what's important is people in process
and
what's most important is the people is
the culture
you've got to have the right culture in
place you've got to have the right
mindset in place in order to succeed
on your devops journey
so as i mentioned i am part of the
devops customer advisory team which is
part of the azure devops
engineering team and azure devops is
microsoft's tool for
doing you speak well used to be called
team foundation server
and it's their tool for to help you
enable
your development processes so it has
work item tracking it has version
control
it has pipelines for doing ci and cd
types of things but one of the things
that we really wanted to happen with the
azure devops platform is we wanted to
work with
any other language and any other
platform so we tried to be as open and
extensible as we could so we integrate
with a lot of different things
you want to use jira to track your work
items but you want to use azure
pipelines to deploy
go ahead you want to use azure boards to
track your work items but you want to
use
jenkins to our chef or puppet to help
with deployments
go ahead we we've tried to be as open as
we can to
to work with to meet you in the middle
where you can use the tools that you
want to use
to get your work done now
we weren't always like this so i want to
take you back
in time just a little bit so what we've
got here
is a comic that came out several years
ago that outlines
the different organizational charts for
some of the major companies at the time
and this was microsoft's organizational
chart
and it's pretty realistic in actuality
because we had different organizations
like with the windows team
and we had the office team and every
team
built software the way they wanted to
build it they used the tools they wanted
to use
they used the processes they wanted to
use they did things the way they wanted
to
and nobody was necessarily doing things
in a consistent manner
which led to a lot of things that you
know weren't great it was very hard to
move engineers from one team to another
because they had to learn brand new
tools brand new processes brand new
everything almost so
satyandella became our ceo back in the
in the middle of the decade and
he brought a couple of great things
to microsoft and one of those things
we're going to mention a lot today
which is this idea of a growth mindset
the idea that it is okay to
fail as long as you learn from your
failures
the other one of the other things he
brought though was the idea of the one
engineering system or one es
he saw that we had all these different
systems that all these different people
were using
and he saw the inefficiencies that that
was causing
so he made the decision that hey let's
get us
all working on the same tools with some
similar processes not necessarily
completely the same processes but
similar processes
and that's going to make everybody more
productive so he brought that in
and implemented that concept for us and
that's a concept that's still ongoing we
have a one
es team inside of microsoft whose goal
is to help the internal teams inside of
microsoft
move to azure devops and move on to um
and and help them with their processes
it's a it's a slow process we've gotten
the windows team moved on
we actually broke git when we put the
windows code base into git because it
was so large
we're onboarding the office team and
then we have other teams that we've been
on boarding as well
so it is it is definitely a journey it's
going to take us you know
years to actually ultimately achieve
that
so let's look though at the road map so
far
for the azure devops
group and microsoft as well so along the
top line we have the roadmap so far for
the azure devops group along the bottom
line we have some
things that we've done in from an open
source perspective
um in the community so team foundation
server started as a boxed product in
2005 that you could just go buy
in 2010 we decided hey we probably need
to start
you know this cloud thing obviously
isn't going away we probably need to
offer
some kind of software as a service for
team foundation server
so in august 2010 we started that
development
and we decided we were going to do
three-week sprints
and it took us about two years to get to
a preview
and you can actually go out and see
every three weeks we've released
something in the sprints and you can go
out to the azure devops blog and you can
actually see
what we've released every sprint um up
even including what we released just i
think last week or the week before
so it took us to about 2012 to to get to
that preview stage
then it took in 2013
i think we actually released in 2014's
when we started our little 1es
journey 2017 we brought windows on to
get
2018 is when we released our upgraded
azure pipelines aspects
and you know every three weeks for the
past
10 years we've been constantly iterating
constantly adding things to the azure
devops product
um so
on the bottom line though we've also
been getting more and more involved in
the open source community which
if you have been around microsoft for a
long time
you realize that that wasn't always the
case but in march 2010 we had 400 open
source projects
uh now i think microsoft is one of the
largest contributors to open source
projects
on github we've released multiple things
as far as like vs code which is
completely open
sourced and out there and as most of you
probably know in 2018 we acquired github
and you know github is one of the
leading
platforms for development
so the five habits though that we've
kind of determined so far
in our devops journey or what i want to
talk about today
and these are the five habits which are
uh being customer obsessed
production first mindset team autonomy
and enterprise alignment which is my
favorite out of all of these to talk
about
shifting left in quality and how you can
do safe deployments and limit
damage that might happen from a bad
deployment so we're going to
talk through all of these things today
now i'm going to go ahead and warn you
normally this is like a three hour talk
but don't worry i've pared it down so we
should get through it
in plenty of time but we're going to
start off
by talking about being customer obsessed
we are running a service and also
delivering an
on-prem version of azure devops server
the on-prem version hasn't gone away
um it's just called azure devops server
now not um azure
devops not team foundation server
but we want to listen to our customers
and especially um we want to provide
different ways for our customers to
provide
us feedback we're providing a product to
them and we want to integrate their
feedback
back into the loop as quickly as we can
so we try to listen to our customers
both quantitatively
um getting a lot of feedback and
qualitatively
making sure that feedback is you know
triaged and
and is good feedback that we can
actually be actionable against
so you have multiple ways to provide us
feedback you can go to developer
community if you go to developer
community and you ask a question
that automatically gets put into our
backlog in azure devops
where it will get triaged and i've seen
the monthly emails that go out that
that lists the top 10 things that have
been voted up into
through developer community and that
those things get triaged into
our work and ultimately has led to
new functionality or exist or changes to
existing functionality in the azure
devops product
we monitor a bunch of social media so if
you go ask questions on stack overflow
and you tag it as your devops
we've got engineers out there that try
to answer this there's a subreddit out
there called azure devops i
try to monitor that subreddit and try to
answer questions there when i can
so so we try to go to where the
community
is to answer questions which is good
feedback for you because
for your customers you should be going
to where the customer
is to try to answer the customer's
questions
on the actual azure devops site
we have the ability for you to um
provide us feedback
so you can make a suggestion or or
or raise an issue and it automatically
will go into the backlog
and if you've been using the product one
of the things you'll see
is every once in a while we're gonna ask
you hey
what do you think of the product and
you're gonna rate it for us and this
rating
is what we use to calculate our net
promoter score
which is a way of determining how
well people like your website
and finally for our top 100 customers
we have what's called a champion for
that customer so
this is a member of the product team
that actually goes out and talks to that
customer once a week once a month
whatever the customer wants
to understand how they're using azure
devops
gather feedback and roll that feedback
into
the planning process these are our top
100 customers with a
that use azure devops extensively so
they have a lot of
of good feedback into how the product is
working
or not working for them so we try to
listen to our customers in a lot of
different ways
being customer obsessed also means that
there are certain things that we want to
measure and certain things that we
don't necessarily care as much about now
a lot of times what we want to measure
also depends on who
we are so for example if i'm a developer
on the feature team
what i want to measure may be a little
bit different than if i'm
mid-level management than if i'm senior
leadership team
but what we found is a lot of the things
we care about since we're running a 24x7
site are things like acquisition how
many people come to the site and
actually
um sign up retention how many people
come back
and use the site at least twice a week
nps score so how satisfied are they with
the site
how fast are we able to build the site
and get the site deployed as you're
going to see
we actually build and deploy azure
devops using
azure devops which is kind of cool and
then of course we're running a live site
now
we have to keep this thing up and
running so we care about
you know how fast can we detect issues
did we detect the issue before somebody
else told us that we did
how fast did we resolve it all of these
are things that that
holistically everybody on all the
different team feature teams inside of
the azure devops organization cares
about
some things we don't watch as much and
this isn't necessarily true team by team
um but some of the things we don't
necessarily
care about as much are we don't
necessarily track
team burn down we don't necessarily
track code coverage we actually do track
number of bugs found
but we do that at a feature team level
so the reason we kind of have this
listed as things we don't watch
is that at the leadership level that's
not stuff they care about
they care about all the stuff that's in
green at the feature team level
yes there are some of these things in
red that the feature teams do care about
but you need to ultimately just measure
what you want to
track one of the things we found is
when we first started with this service
is we turned on
all kind of monitoring that we could and
the problem we encountered is
we gathered so much data we didn't know
what to do with it
which is why we kind of stepped back and
were very precise in what we wanted to
try to measure
so when we build out new features we
have about 45 feature teams on the azure
devops engineering team
and when we build out new features we
kind of follow this
whole build measure learn um
way of doing things so we make a guess
we make a hypothesis
that we believe that you want this
feature because of this reason
then we go out build it deploy it
and start monitoring it and start
determining
are people using the feature how are
they using the feature
are they using the feature the same way
that um
we expected them to use the feature so
it's not just about
building it or guessing what they want
building it and then
deploying it and ignoring it we've got
to gather the feedback
and learn how people are using what what
we've deployed out
there and honestly
we don't always get it right and this is
where
satya has come in with growth mindset
and and shown us that it's okay to fail
as long as you learn from it
so again we don't always get it right
for example in 2013 for um we released
something called team rooms
inside of team foundation server this
was basically our way of competing with
slack
it was built into the product and we
thought this is what developers wanted
and we thought they were just going to
flock to it
and ultimately what we found is nobody
used it
so a few years later we
took it out of the product we admitted
to the fact that hey
this isn't working and rather than
continue to throw resources at it
to try to make it work let's just
take it out readjust those resources and
move on
and that goes back to the fact that we
had implemented this monitoring and
learning aspect
because we want to be customer obsessed
and provide our customers
exactly what they want
so first habit customer obsessed
second habit is we need to have a
production
first mindset we are running a
24x7 service used by millions of people
we need to make sure that that is always
up and running but here's the problem
we've never
done it we started building this product
back in 2010
and before that all the experience on
this team was building
boxed software that we shipped
so now we have a service that we're
going to constantly update every three
weeks
and we need to make sure it stays up all
the time so we had to figure out how do
we do this
the first step was we have
41 feature teams building out new
features
how do we know when a feature is done
we had to come up with what we
considered our definition of done
so we consider a feature to be done
or an update to a feature to be done
when it is
live in production so it's been deployed
collecting telemetry so we have
monitoring on it that's coming back
and that we are reviewing and looking at
that either supports or diminishes the
starting hypothesis
so the monitoring the telemetry that
comes back is either
saying you built the right thing or you
didn't build the right thing
it is important really no matter what
type of software you're building
that you have some sort of definition of
done
so that is something to keep in mind but
this was our definition of done
so of how we were going to handle the
fact that since we're constantly
evolving this service how do we know
when something is done
we also had to figure out how to handle
live
site incidents or lsi's
because we're running a live site and
it's going to have problems
so we've evolved this over time
but the way it works right now is
when we detect an issue either through
our monitoring or through somebody
alerting us that there was an issue
then we immediately spin up an lsi
bridge
and then the dris are brought on welcome
to microsoft home of more acronyms than
you can imagine we actually have an
internal tool
where you can search for acronyms to
understand what those acronyms are
the dris are what's called the
designated responsible
individual every feature
team is responsible for their feature
in production so every week
somebody from each feature team is on
call they are considered the dri
so if you have 12 people on your feature
team
then once a quarter for a week you are
on call
and on call means if there's a problem
and an lsi conference bridge is spun
up you have five minutes to get on that
call during the week
and 15 minutes to get on it during
nights and weekends
and it's actually satya nadella
recording of him calling you saying hey
there's a problem would you mind getting
on the call
so when we have a live site incident we
spin up this bridge
the dris are brought on the call and
they start trying to
honestly solve the problem they'll bring
in other people if they need to
we'll reach out to the azure team or
other teams if we need you to help us
from to help us with
um doing things we'll rotate people in
and out of those calls as we need to
to if it's especially if it's a long
running call and
we need to track everything related to
our live site instance
so that we can hopefully make it where
they don't happen again what you see on
the right side of the screen
is our incident management system this
is not our help desk system this
is our icm our instant management system
that we
built internally just for managing live
site
incidents and in that system we capture
things like time to detect time to
mitigate
we capture how we how we determined that
it was an issue
how we trouble shot the issue how we
resolved it
at the bottom you can see there are
repair items
which are work items for things we need
to go do to make sure this doesn't
happen again
so it's very important if you're going
to have a production first mindset
that when you have issues you track
everything around that issue so that
you're able to know what caused it
and how you fixed it so that you
hopefully can put some monitoring and
such in place to where it doesn't happen
again
one of the rules we have is that if
someone alerts us to a live site
incident before
one of our automatic monitors does then
we need to in the next six weeks in the
next two sprints we need to put
something in place
so that we we can automatically detect
whatever that is
so we're trying to constantly improve
our monitoring as we go forward
live site is is top priority this is
actually one of our
our knocks that we have for our site
reliability engineers
to help us with the with the live sites
we do
weekly live site reviews
so they have a weekly review and anyone
who is involved in a live site incident
goes to this review to provide the
information about that review
if we've had to make a quick fix or push
something into production
to solve a problem to get things working
we then have six weeks
two sprints to be able to push that back
through our full
formal process so that we can um
make sure it goes through all of our
formal process and gets redeployed again
this is i mean this is super important
the whole dri thing the whole feature
team being responsible for the code
in production is a game change was a
game changer for us
and that's actually when i talked to
customers it seems to be a game changer
for them as well
we also found it was important to
provide an accurate service status page
so if you go to status.dev.azure.com you
can see the status
of azure devops that way
customers can go and see where things
stand without necessarily just
pinging out on twitter or trying to say
hey
is the service up or not
we also as part of production first and
also being customer obsessed
we're transparent about the problems
and this is something a lot of customers
i talk to
um their it organizations necessarily
aren't that transparent when there's
issues
and what you're going to find is if you
fess up if you tell
people what happened and why it happened
and what you're going to do to make sure
it doesn't happen again
they're going to respect you more and
it's actually going to make a better
bond between you
and the customer a couple of examples
we have um look at that graph on the on
the left
because it's going to come back but we
had an event the visual studio
um online launch event in 2013 when this
product
launched we had a major some major
issues there which i'll explain what
happened a little bit later
but we were very upfront and honest
about this is what happened
um brian harry wrote a several page blog
post on what happened
what we're doing to make sure that
doesn't happen in the future back in
august
september of 2018 lightning struck
a data center azure data center in texas
and basically brought azure devops down
for almost two days
we were upfront about what happened
there and why that occurred
and what we've put in place now to make
sure that doesn't happen again
it's fun note um at the top there that
little green
visual studio team services is up and
running that was our status page at the
time
and even though azure devops was called
visual studio team services then
was down the status page kept saying it
was up
because we couldn't get to the servers
in that data center to change the status
page
which is why having a good status page
is important
but being transparent with your
customers being open with your customers
being empathetic with your customers
it's going to serve you well long term
because it's going to make a better bond
between you and those customers
now we've built out this service that
we're deploying every three weeks and
initially
deployments were manual and then they
were
partially automated but there were still
some manual
every time we moved to a new environment
there were still some manual things that
we needed to do
and
one of our our tenants that have come
out of this is there's no such thing as
partial automation
because what we had an issue with one
time is we had a bunch of these
deployment commands that we had to run
that were in onenote much powershell
so we would cut and paste from onenote
into the powershell command line window
so we had commands like this
and if you've ever cut and paste from
word
or onenote into a command line window
then you know
that those aren't real quotes you have
to backspace
over them and replace them so imagine
having a dozen steps like that where you
have to backspace over them and replace
them
and then you miss one and you break
pre-production for half a day or a day
because you missed one of these manual
steps
i can't tell you how many customers i go
and talk to who feel like they have
a really solid ci cd pipeline in place
but they're deploying as they deployed
each environment they then remote into
the server to make manual configuration
changes
that's partial automation and partial
automation is bad
and we after one too many times of
having issues
we learned that and decided that we were
going to fix that
so now we automate everything completely
we still have a big chunk of powershell
scripts that are used for
helping do the deployments but we've got
those in version control
and we've got those running as part of
azure pipelines
and we deploy to every environment the
same way so whether we're deploying to
canary
to dev to test to qa to prod we're
deploying to the
same environment the same way every time
using the same tools
which in this case is after pipelines
security has also become very important
and i'm sure
everyone on this call will probably
agree that security is
is something that we need to keep in the
forefront of our mind
so with this in mind we started off by
saying
hey let's have a red team and a blue
team
so the red team will be constantly
trying to break in
and the blue team will be constantly
trying to catch the red team
initially we would do things like for
the next three days we're gonna do a war
games red team try to break in blue team
try to catch them
over time we got rid of the blue team
because we decided that everyone in the
azure devops organization
needs to be part of the blue team they
need to be constantly aware
of phishing attacks constantly aware of
something doesn't look right i need to
tell somebody something
and i've gotten phishing attack emails
from the red
team during my time here at microsoft
that then we've
we've turned into the appropriate people
but
security needs to be something that
we're constantly
doing and handling another
area where we're trying to be more
secure is
shifting left with security trying to
implement security
earlier in the development cycle
not just worrying about security once
it's live and out in production
but trying to do things earlier in the
system
trying to make sure that we don't check
code into
version control that has connection
strings with user ids and passwords in
it
or personal access tokens to azure or
aws
trying to make sure that we're not using
vulnerable oss packages
these are all things that we've done to
try to
make sure that before that code even
gets merged into the master branch
it is been scanned and we've removed a
lot of these vulnerabilities
and github has some great options for
this too if you've not seen their
dependency management and
and some of the other things see there
about opening up a pull request telling
you hey
this open source package you're using is
out of date go check it out
but we try to shift our security earlier
in the development
cycle to solve the problems before
they're even getting deployed
all right doing good so far now we're at
my favorite part of this talk
which is the team autonomy and
enterprise alignment part
so we've talked customer obsession we've
talked production first mindset
now we're going to talk team autonomy
and enterprise alignment
but first i want to tell you a story
so we have two groups so this is a true
story
we have two groups we have group a
who's making a product now group a is a
business that's been around for a while
they're well established people know who
they are they've got money they hire the
best people
and they're wanting to make this product
and we have group b group b
is making a similar competing product
but the difference is it's not a company
it's just
a group of people that are doing it in
their spare time because they want to
work on what they're doing they believe
in what they're doing
so this is a true true story normally
when you say hey which group would
succeed it's
most people think group a because you
know they've got the money they can hire
the best people this is their day jobs
what they're supposed to work on
but if we actually look at the players
in this story
we've got group a which is microsoft and
carta
and we have group b which is wikipedia
and if you want to know what microsoft
encarta
is you can read about it on wikipedia
group b one microsoft and carter was
a digital multimedia encyclopedia
so we have these two different groups
building the same thing
and ultimately group b won because they
felt like they had autonomy
mastery and purpose they felt like they
had a little bit of control
of their destiny so in microsoft
we're always finding books to read and
one of the books we found was by daniel
pink called drive
and drive came out i think 2010 or so
still a great book still should read it
talks about what
motivates teams and what motivates
people
and initially what motivated people is
food and shelter
then it was money but research now shows
what really
motivates people especially teams of
people is when they have three things
autonomy mastery and purpose and they
feel like they have some control over
their destiny
so the agile devops team decided okay
how do we
our we have 41 feature teams how do we
give them some autonomy
but still ensure that we can you know
track everything and make sure that
we've got
um everything getting built that needs
to get built
and we decided to go with what we called
aligned autonomy so we made a list of
all the different things that we might
want to care about
and we decided that the top
five were going to be things that every
feature team will be aligned on
we're going to have the same role so
we're going to call them um engineers
we're going to call them
program managers we're going to have the
same cadence
so every feature team is going to
deliver on a three-week cadence
we're going to have the same taxonomy so
we're going to call work items the same
thing
and but when it gets to the actual
individual feature teams we're going to
give them some autonomy on
how they do things so some teams may do
hardcore scrum
some teams may do scrum light some teams
may just use a combo board
we're gonna we're gonna let them how
they want to plan things and the
different practices they want to use
inside that feature team every team's
allowed to be different
but we're all going to be aligned on
these core items that affect
all the different teams and by providing
them that autonomy
the members of the feature teams feel
like they have some skin
in the game they feel like they are
involved they feel like they have the
ability to make decisions that affect
themselves
and that makes them more productive
a quick talk on roles that we have at
microsoft
used to be we had program managers dev
and testers
and developers did no testing they threw
it over the wall to the testers
so there was a great calling at one
point where we basically said
that's not going to work and we still
kept program management but then we
created engineering
which is which is basically developers
who also text so we have program
management and we have engineering now
as our two main roles
program management think of them as kind
of like the business analysts they're
still very technical
but they're determining what we're
building and why we're building it
they're talking to the customers
engineering is concerned with how we're
going to build it and making sure that
we're building things that are quality
now when we form teams the feature teams
that we form
usually we have one or two program
managers and the rest
engineering and in that each feature
team is made up of some program managers
and some engineers
we have bought into the team room
concept and an idea of a team room
is you have a large open room that
everybody sits in to do their work
one of the things that microsoft that it
used to be is you always got an office
with a door
you might have to share it with someone
but you always got an office with a door
now we've moved to the more i the idea
of these physical team rooms some people
love them some people hate them
but overall we found that it does help
us increase our communication
our teams are usually about 10 to 12
people
and they're self-managing they form
without necessarily managers being told
you're on this team you're on this team
and i'll show you how we do that in just
a moment
the feature teams themselves have a
clear charter and goals of what they're
trying to accomplish
and they own the features in production
and they own when those features are
deployed
so each feature team can determine when
it's when the feature is deployed
and they can also determine um they but
then they're also responsible for making
sure that
once that feature is in production if
there's an issue with it
they have to solve the problem
with that feature
so this the sticky note exercise is how
we actually
um form our teams so every 12 to 18
months
we go into the conference room and we
put all the different feature teams
up on the boards and you're given three
sticky notes and you put your first
and your second and your third choice
this is an opportunity for you to be
able to change
teams without doing any kind of formal
interview or any kind of top down reorg
it's driven by the employees not the
managers
haven't seen this done anywhere else
it's only been done as far as i've seen
at microsoft
and usually less than about 20 percent
of the people want to change
teams because they're building out these
teams because
they are they're on this team because
they you know like what they're doing
but everybody gets the choice to change
teams if they want to
and by allowing people to move to
different teams
we're able to cross pollinate the teams
and make sure that
um if somebody wins the lottery and
decides to quit we don't lose a lot of
domain knowledge
when they decide to quit
from a planning perspective we've got a
book that has started to influence our
planning
um it's called measure what matter it's
about okrs
and we've changed our planning to where
we now have
a month strategy two six month semesters
four quarters and then we have sprints
so a sprint is three weeks
a quarter is four sprints or 12 weeks
and then a semester
is six months or two quarters and then
we have
the strategy so we lay out the strategy
for the whole year
and in broad strokes for each semester
leadership is responsible for that
then the teams goes back to that whole
aligned autonomy we're aligned
at the 12-month strategy level but the
teams are responsible for building out
the detail
of what they're going to build to hit
that big picture
over these time frames and when it's
going to deploy
measure what matters it's a book on okrs
which is called objectives and key
results this is
all the rage right now for how people
are doing planning
and the idea is you're going to define
an objective
which is something you want to
accomplish and you're going to define a
key result
which is how you measure whether you
accomplished that objective
and we're very open with these um
they're they're posted out when anyone
can see them
and the reason this has been helpful is
because if a team needs to understand
what they need to work on or with what
they're doing is the right direction
they can go look at the defined
objectives and key results for
that quarter to know if they're helping
push
those objectives and key results forward
for example this is an example of one of
the objectives and key results from
azure pipelines grow a strong and happy
customer base
objectives are supposed to be nebulous
they're not measurable
but then you'll notice that the key
results are specific things that we can
measure
so you define a nebulous objective and
then the specific key results to help
you know if you've hit that objective
the other thing that's encouraged if you
follow this mindset and i highly
recommend you read this book
is your your
key results should be ambitious you
really should only hit about seventy
percent of your key results if you get
more if you hit more than seventy
percent of your key results
you probably didn't push yourself as
hard as you could have
now we have 41 feature teams each
releasing every three weeks
we had to figure out a way of how do we
stay in sync
so how do we you know we could do
uh retrospectives at the end of every
sprint and then we'd spend the entire
next sprint almost doing retrospectives
so microsoft is an email heavy customer
or email heavy company
so we decided to go with what we call
the sprint mail so at the end of every
sprint we send out sprint mails that
that show what the different feature
teams did for that
sprint and then at the end of every two
sprints
we check in on our okrs to see hey are
we going to hit them has anything
changed and then at the every end of
every four sprints which is every
quarter
we do an okr reset so every quarter we
review our okrs and change those
depending on
you know whatever's changed in the world
that makes us want to
change what our objectives were our
sprint males initially started out as
every feature team sent out a sprint
mail and it was basically
this is what we did this sprint this is
what we're going to do next sprint
um and maybe has you know some demos in
it for people to see
what we found is we were sending out 41
of these emails
and people weren't necessarily reading
them because there were so many emails
getting sent they were just getting put
into a folder
so we changed this a little bit when we
went with okrs to where now
we kind of roll this up into into our
our objectives and our epics so that
maybe instead of
all five feature teams on the azure port
team sending out an email
just the azure board principal program
manager sends out an email
that covers everything that all five
teams did
but instead of just saying this is what
we did this is what we're doing next
month
we also tie it back to the objectives
and the key results that we've defined
so we're able to see how the work we've
done helps
push those okrs forward
all right stick with me we only got we
got two left we got
15 minutes we're doing great so
we've talked customer obsession
production first mindset
team autonomy and enterprise alignment
next up
shifting left on quality how do we
ensure
quality earlier in the development cycle
we talked about that a little bit with
security already
so how do we go fast and not break
things
well the first thing that we we decided
is
if we're going to go fast and not break
things we've got to do it
by not incurring debt and specifically
bug debt so one of the first things we
implemented
and is what we call our bug cap so we
take the number of engineers on your
team let's call it 10
and multiply that by a number we've
played with this number a lot right now
it's four
and that is your bug cap number so for a
team with 10 engineers
that the bud cap is 40. what the bug cap
means is
if at the end of a sprint you're over
your bug cap you have 40 or more bugs
the next sprint all you're doing is
building or no all you're doing is
fixing bugs
you're not getting to build new software
you're not getting to add new features
all you're doing the next sprint is
fixing bugs
this one thing right here when we
implemented it made our quality go
through the roof
because developers don't like fixing
bugs developers like writing new
software
writing new code so when we put this in
place
it made them go oh i don't want to have
to fix bugs i want to write new code
i've seen companies take this and put
this in place and they've and see their
quality increase this is probably one of
the easiest things you could do
to get yourself started on getting
better at devops
we also changed how we do our branching
so we moved to get from tfvc and
we've moved to kind of this release flow
trunk based development type of
branching
where essentially we have our main line
and we have feature branches off of
those mainline in this case they're
calling them topic branches
now the key with our feature branches is
we try to keep them short-lived
however sometimes it takes two or three
weeks to build a feature
so what we do is we're constantly
pulling and pushing from master
so we're constantly merging back into
the main line and we're constantly
pulling from the main line
and we do this using feature flags so
we're
able to hide the code that's not ready
yet with feature flags
now when we get ready to release we do
create a release branch and we release
off of that release branch
if we find a problem during the release
we fix it on master and then cherry pick
it down into the release and the reason
we fix it on master is so that
any feature branches out there the next
time they do a pull
um it will actually um they'll get that
hot fix
but remember our branches we try to keep
them short-lived they're not always
short-lived but if they're not
we're constantly pulling and pushing
from the mainline
using feature flags to hide the code
that's not ready
in fact out in azure devops right now
there is code out there right now
hidden by feature flags that you're not
aware of
we also started making use of pull
requests as
a way to ensure quality so our pull
requests
before you can merge from a branch back
to the main line we have multiple things
that have to happen we have a whole
bunch of unit tests that have to run
we have some some manual um
approvals that have to happen we're
using this to ensure that the quality of
code that makes it back to the main line
is much much better which ensures the
release will go better
in fact you can see on the the right
hand side
all the different branch policies that
are required to
pass before we could do a merge from
from this branch back to the main line
all of these different builds have to
pass
we have a whole bunch of tests that have
to pass in this case we're only running
a subset of them we're running about 28
000 unit tests
that run in about three minutes or less
but we could run our full suite of unit
tests which i think
takes 25 minutes to run and ensure that
we haven't done anything to
break things before it gets back into
master
we also decided green means green and
red means red
so
if we're going to have all these little
unit
all these different tests runs that we
want to run over here on the left hand
side
on a particular build then it needs
everything needs to pass before we move
this on
it used to be we would look at it and we
would go oh that test
failed it's okay that that test failed
because
um it doesn't really matter so move on
into production anyway
we no longer do that if we have a test
either it has to pass or
we don't deploy or we need to remove
that test
there's no reason to have tests out
there that are flaky tests that
sometimes work sometimes don't
and therefore you just skip them when
you feel like it
we changed how we do our testing we used
to we had a lot of
these end-to-end scenario tests that
took forever to run
and a lot of times we couldn't even run
those until we got into production or
close to production
so we decided to change our tactic on
testing and go with
more unit testing so we have a lot more
what we call
l0 and l1 tests which are unit tests and
then we have some l2 tests that's a ml3
test which are functional tests or tests
that we run in production
but we bought all in on moving over to
unit testing
and we started this process we had 26
000 28
000 of these long running scenario tests
and very few unit tests
and so what we decided to do was
as we wrote new code that new code had
to have a unit test
and as we touch existing code if that
code didn't have a unit test
we had to create a unit test for it
and we went started this journey
to move more toward unit testing and
when i tell this story to customers
they get all excited and they turn to
you and i t and they say hey go do this
make it happen in a month
it took us two and a half years
you can see at some point there was an
inflection point where we had the same
amount of unit tests as we had these
scenario tests
and then now we've gotten up to even
that number is not right i think it's
closer to 90 000 unit tests that we have
and the key with our unit test is they
have to run fast
we should be we can run our entire suite
of unit tests i think in less than 30
minutes
but we're ensuring again that quality
we've now gone all the way to the pull
request level of a feature branch
and our insuring quality there before it
even gets to maine
and can then get deployed
okay last thing safe deployments and
limiting damage
we're not going to always get this right
we're not going to always get our
deployments correctly
so how do we control the blast radius
how do we make sure we just don't
blow everything up for everybody
so some of the early principles that we
put in place were things like
we need to use deploy the same way into
all the different environments
so no more partial automations
we need to make sure the quality signal
signals
that we're trying to follow all those
green tests
we do it the same way every time we
needed our deployments to take zero
downtime
and we wanted the deployments to happen
during working hours
so right now we deploy azure devops
using azure devops and we start at
8am on monday morning and if everything
goes right by 5 pm on friday we've
deployed azure devops
it doesn't alway it doesn't always
happen that way but that's the goal
and no partial automation these were all
our early principles
one of the other aspects of devops that
we bought into to do this though to do
our branching model the way we wanted to
was this idea of feature flags because
feature flags
decouple deployment from exposure i've
got a lot of stuff up in azure devops
right now that you're not even aware of
because it's hidden by a feature flag
but when i'm ready
i can turn it on and those features will
be there for you
and then if something goes wrong or it's
not working correctly i can turn them
back off
so feature flags are a great way to
allow you to do
that constant pulling and pushing for
master which you need to do to make sure
you don't have really bad merges
and a way to also determine when you
deploy your or when you actually expose
your code for people to use it
so feature flags are awesome what could
go wrong well
we were gonna launch visual studio
online in 2013
and right before the big launch event
we turned on everything
i turn on all the feature flags we
pushed all this code out there all this
stuff was hidden
we turned on all these feature flags and
um we brought the system up and down for
about a week
you may remember this graphic from
earlier when i talked about brian harry
giving us a
um being open and honest about what
happened the issue was we had tested
everything but what we really hadn't
tested was what happens when we flip
all those flags on at the same time and
the interactions
so nowadays in the future if you're
going to speak an event any feature
flags has to be thrown about 48 hours in
advance
we also decided that we needed to do
progressive
excuse me do progressive exposure in how
we're
um deploying so we have multiple
rings that we deploy to now we go to one
stage at a time the first ring is the
canary ring
that's the azure devops group itself we
dog food our product then we deploy to a
data center
that's got some users that have signed
on to always stay on the latest and
greatest
so they know it might may or may not be
stable
then we deploy to a data center with a
large number of users so we can can get
a lot of people interacting with the
syst
with the update we deploy to an overseas
data center so we can test latency
and then we deploy out to everybody else
as you can see we're actually
using azure pipelines to deploy azure
pipelines
we use the current product to deploy the
new version of the product
one of the other things we're starting
to get into is this idea of
chat ops so we've actually built a
bot called as dd for
um azure devops for microsoft teams
where we can go in and ask where are
things in the deployment
and as dd can come back and say
oh here's where the deployments are in
the different rings here
here's where you might be having an
issue in a particular ring and then you
can actually have it
drive you into the azure pipeline to
where the actual issue
is so you can start seeing what's
happening
so this is a new thing that we're just
you know are starting to try to get into
but we're finding that that
that things like this are very helpful
because we're
again bringing information to where our
team members are living
now your azure devops journey is going
to follow
what we call the j curve okay j curve
starts over here on the left and
you begin a transformation you identify
some quick wins
a lot of time those quick wins are
things like um automation
like putting some pipelines in place and
you're thinking this is great devops is
awesome and then you enter what i call
the valley of sorrow
because that's where it gets hard that's
where you've got your quick wins that
you could get with tooling
but now you're having to change your
people and you're having to change your
process
and that's where a lot of people give up
and that's where i've got to encourage
you don't give up
it's the valley of sorrow is hard that's
where you're changing the culture that
you that you live in
but you reach a point where you push
through that
and then you hit the top of that j curve
and
suddenly it clicks and it's like
everything just seems to be working
you're deploying faster
you're deploying higher quality code
so i i have to encourage people when
you're doing this to to make sure that
you you know you're going to be excited
initially and then it's going to get
hard
and you got to stick to the hard part to
where
you come out the other side even better
so moving into 2020 we have a lot of
different things we're trying to do a
little more intersourcing we're trying
to
shift even farther left with security
and compliance we're we're searching
some better ways to do resilience or
chaos engineering
still trying to you know this these are
all things some of our plans at the
beginning of the year
now your devops journey in general has
it's gonna have its ups and downs that
whole j-curve
but it's worth it at the end and i got
one more slide to show you exactly why
it's worth it at the end
and that's this one right here features
delivered per year by the azure devops
team
so our transformation over the years has
allowed us to deliver
more and more value to customers at a
faster and faster velocity
each time so you could see back in 2012
we delivered 22 features
and then you could see we were moving
steadily moving up i mean hockey stick
curving to where in 2017 we delivered
364 features
well in 2018 it kind of dropped off and
you may be wondering why it dropped off
well it dropped off because of gdpr
we had to stop and do a whole bunch of
work to make sure we're gdpr compliant
and we also started re-architecting on
some of azure devops at that point
because right now when we deploy azure
devops we deploy
everything so we started re-architecting
things into individual services so that
we could just deploy
azure boards or we could just deploy
azure pipelines
and that's it that's what i've got for
you so i really appreciate your time
um i'll i've got three minutes so i'll
see if there's any questions that people
have if you have them go to
conference room three and slack
otherwise at 7 40
we'll drop off this but i'll keep
answering questions in slack for a
little bit if you have any questions
uh you're welcome to reach out to me hit
me up on twitter shoot me an email
happy to try to answer any questions you
might have um
around devops so thank you very much i
appreciate it
so let's see what we got so
can you give an update about the future
of the on-prem version of azure devops
server
so it's it's alive and kicking so
we release to azure devops service the
cloud version
every three weeks every three months we
take
all the updates that we made every three
weeks
and um
make we roll those into one update for
the on-prem
version so the self-hosted version of
azure
devops so azure devops server is usually
always about three weeks behind
or three months behind the what we've
got up in the cloud
so will azure devops merge with github
actions
at some point so azure devops and github
are two distinct
two distinct products um obviously
github
is is a premier destination for
developers
especially for developers doing open
source but just for developers in
general
and sorry you hear my dog in the
background and azure devops is still
alive and strong and doing what it's
doing as well so i'm not aware of
anything where they're going to to merge
at any point in time in the future
so there's a question thanks mickey for
the enlightened talk
um who line manages your developers if
they can change teams like that do their
managers change each time
so if they do change from one feature
team to the other
their managers could change yes so
be based off of whether they stayed on
that feature team or on a feature team
that was
in that particular area or whether they
moved to a new area
so it it it it depends that usually
um it could there's team leads on the
development team but yes it could change
every time
hush it's okay
um do we have cases where there is a
difference in opinion about what should
be prioritized when it comes to feature
functionality between teams and
management and if so
how do you handle this um
that's a very good question i'm sure
there are cases
where what should be prioritized
varies depending on on who you on who
you are excuse me one second
everyone meet ollie he's being a pain um
so as far as how they handle it
i i know that the teams are told from a
broad perspective
this is what they need to work on this
is these are the the
long-range priorities they they can then
determine
you know they can then determine the
specific priorities they're trying to do
for that sprint
and they have to make a case for it if
they can make the case for it that's
great if they can't make the case for it
then i'm sure there's some some changes
that are made there
i'll be honest i'm not sure that the the
details of exactly how it's done
but i'll tell you what i will find out
and if you'll give me some
shoot me some contact information i will
be happy to send you some details on
those questions
this would be great but the last feature
update the on-prem version is a long
time ago
okay fair enough let me go find out
where things stand for you
on the current feature update for the
on-prem version and and i will provide
you some feedback on that again if you
want to send me an email
then and give me a chance to go ask the
feature team about where
about where things stand with the latest
update i will let you know we
usually we've been pretty consistent
about getting the updates out there
every three every three months i know
some months i know
sometimes we did not do that but let me
see what i can find out for you
all right i know i punted on a couple of
your questions because i wasn't quite
sure what the answers were
if again give me a chance to find you
some answers
shoot me an email with some contact
information and i'll be happy to find
those for you
for everyone else you're welcome to
shoot me questions in the future i'm
going to
put ollie outside and then i'll i'll
come back and answer questions in slack
thank you all very much